indeed the city has served as a co-star
in the last several of his films what do
you and he look for in each city that
makes a film uniquely Rome or Paris or
London or Barcelona or Manhattan well
just look for all the scenery that you
see when you watch one of the movies and
you look for the beautiful parts of a
city and there are many more than you
have time to do and it's really mainly
Woody's I that see something and can
have the vision of what it would look
like on the screen I guess you've seen
some of that tonight in tonight's
picture and if you remember some of the
older pictures you would have seen it in
New York and/or last year in Midnight in
Paris the wonderful opening montage of
such beautiful beautiful scenery in
Paris yeah well he seems to fall in love
with the city and I'm just curious does
does the idea for the film come first
and then he goes to the city to co
expand it what does he go spend time in
a city and let that sort of drive some
inspiration um it works both ways in the
case of Rome it I mean he'd been there
before obviously would he has a little
jazz band he tours with and he goes out
usually at least once a year for a
couple of weeks most of his tours are in
Europe although he has toured in America
and
uh he sees cities he's been to them many
times and see something he likes about
them then Along Came Medusa in this case
and I guess he felt very comfortable
with the idea of doing a picture in Rome
and we did it yeah well I believe this
was his first film in Italy and he may
have been comfortable but for you as a
producer what were the particular
challenges of shooting in Rome other
than the traffic um initially finding
local crew key people local line
producer and you know we have a
wonderful line producer who's probably
done more pictures with woody than I
have Helen Robin and she'll go over and
kind of line up all the key members of a
crew would you pick the cinematographer
then it's a question of cameramen and
whatnot usually we find locals for most
of it sometimes will bring people with
us but and it hasn't been a problem that
there were wonderful people in the film
business everywhere we've worked and it
seems to run smoothly